a hundred liberal writers signed an open
letter in Harper's condemning canceled
culture as an attack on free thought to
which I say better late than never
a wise man once said every good deed
could have been done sooner so I applaud
them for joining the fight finally even
though some of them they didn't seem to
mind cancel culture when it takes aim at
people like you or me in fact some of
them did take aim at me and maybe you
but now see it's targeting them and they
could lose a book deal hence the letter
it's the old adage that liberals should
have learned by now you can be nice to a
crocodile but he'll still eat you
they'll be at last so the open letter is
cute but why not actively defend people
who are being cancelled right now who
aren't part of this elite group that
signed the letter why not help those
who've lost their jobs and not just
speaking engagements instead they say
they want to end cancel culture because
its existence will help Trump know you
should want to end it because you helped
create it it rose from the toxic mud of
academia energized by the cowardice of
liberals and media politics and business
the counselors can smell their fear so
if you say something that they don't
like they'll contact your workplace and
hound your bosses online until you're
finally fired the First Amendment
matters little if they could still ruin
your career in life yesterday I asked
where is the silent majority the answer
in hiding from an unstable angry mob
these open letter warriors should fight
for them not just for themselves the
people who make a stupid mistake and
lose their jobs they don't have rich
friends I mean we could win this thing
if we fight this thing together but do
it alone
you lose boom so Kennedy I actually love
the letter I mean it's kind of bland I
love it but there's part of me that is
bothered by the fact that they're doing
it now because they finally feel the
heat that other people have felt I was
wondering when this was going to happen
I was wondering when we were going to
arrive at the point where rabid ultra
leftists would wake up and be reasonable
for a second because canceled culture it
knows no bounds
it knows no party and it's a very very
hungry beast and as we have seen
appeasing it does nothing because there
is no end game if you have a list of
demands that you think you're going to
meet and in the end the out range that's
never going to happen they will they
will come up with new items on that list
they will come up with new lists and new
enemies and guess what it doesn't matter
if you are one of the coastal elites
they are coming for you so it's about
damn time that someone as a group stood
up for free speech especially that which
you disagree with most yeah now one if
they had asked you to sign this letter
would you have mm I'm not sure I think
so but I mean I you know I I resist sort
of joining in any kind of Club like that
and you saw it in terms of the response
from some on the far left who said hey
these are people with high-paying jobs
who are just worried about losing their
next speech that you know they're not
speaking out for everyone but Greg III
agreed for the most part because you
know you know I've been fired for
speaking my mind right so I've lost a
job because of this I literally wrote a
book called muzzle Lee assault on honest
debate about this but what you know
what's ironic and what troubles me and
the reason I would have hesitated is
that I think that ideological debate
today is more open than it's ever been
in large part because no matter what
your voice carries there's a social
media platform for you today those
voices are going to get heard more so
than ever before and I think that's a
good thing you know people talk about
canceled culture but you know it plays
Justice Kennedy says it plays on the
left it plays on the right President
Trump just recently is trying to block a
book by his niece he's trying to block
Bolton's book you know he tries to
that's not you think so culture JC's
license that's what I think it that's I
think you'll change somebody up below
which
yeah I know we have a delay okay
kick canceling cancel culture targets
people's careers and tries to ruin them
we're not talking about a person writing
a tell-all book we're talking about
obscure people who make a mistake and
they're their entire lives are destroyed
in this case there's a group of people
saying we've had enough and grant it you
know they could you know they might be
immune to it but maybe they're supposed
to be the right people to do it at this
time ya know so what I see what I think
is if you try to tell somebody you can't
write this book I don't want to hear
what you have to say if you say to a
critic oh I think you're a murderer like
you said about Joe Scarborough
I think that's cancel culture as an
attempt to shut somebody up to muzzle Z
so for my money I disagree I think we
gotta move on here let me finish my
point I think that you can't use this to
excuse people who would spread lies who
would have calls to violence conspiracy
theories racism anti-semitism sexism gay
bashing that's not that's not what we're
talking about here let's talk about
honest debate all right Jesse you can
comment on what Lanza said that he kind
of pushed his cancer culture out to
encapsulate a whole bunch of things what
what say you
you were probably the prime target for
cancellation at any time probably by the
people who wrote this open letter yeah
if there is a betting pool and who is
going to get cancelled off the show I'd
probably be winning but yeah no I agree
with your monologue this was about self
preservation it wasn't about principles
there was crickets when the Republicans
were getting scalped left and right I
mean these people created the mob the
mob turned on him and now they're trying
to change the rules of the middle of it
to protect their own hide it reminds me
of one of your other monologues when you
highlighted the guy who was cheering on
the rioters until the rioters came to
his neighborhood and burned his
neighborhood down and then he was
on the phone with 911 let's say where
are you but they do this in the middle
of the game to protect their power and
and they do this a lot like they'll
create a movement and then drop it when
it's politically expedient like they did
with Chazz they did it with black face
with masks they done it with the me2
movement they've done it with the de
fund the police movement and it's
interesting to watch because the the
left is always on offense when it comes
to the culture war the right is always
on defense and trust me
defense does not win championships
because it's a death by a thousand cuts
they're gonna throw litigation they're
gonna get you fired they're gonna have
legislation I mean it's just a full-out
assault and all of a sudden Trump comes
along and he picks up a sword and says
let's go on offense guys and he starts
going after the media he starts going
after the deep state and the the
anti-christmas people and the statue top
lers and what does the Republican Party
do they not only don't grab a sword
they don't even pick up a shield and
defend they just go silent and they've
just sat there this whole time and
haven't even participated in the culture
war and that is no way to win this thing
yeah good point you know Dana I got I
got a lot of viewers ticked off at me
when I was talking about whether the
silent majority existed and I got a lot
of emails from people saying what would
you have us do if we aren't silent
we'll probably lose our jobs I think
they're referring to if they talk about
supporting Trump or wearing a red hat or
criticizing a movement like black lives
matters that they're gone yeah and I
understood your point and I think that
of course they are polite and they send
you an email and they say but what about
us and I think that you understand them
as well because you've said on the show
before we're super privileged to be here
on the five we have a place where we are
free to say whatever we want
we have bosses that back us up is like
free speech absolutist so we are in a
much better position than a lot of
people because you do see that the
consequences of speaking up are not just
well
maybe you had a bad couple weeks it's
that you actually lose your ability to
feed your family so when I agree that
with one that has never been a time when
you could express your feelings more
openly and have a debate but what's
different now is that you have a
situation where people will then call up
your employer and demand that you be
fired and then it's very hard for
anybody to get a job after that and
remember the Mozilla CEO because he had
given $1,000 to prop 8 which was the
anti gay marriage rule referendum in
California but that was at the same time
that Barack Obama expressly that was his
position at the time and everybody
reached back and got him this past week
Boeing had an executive who lost his job
for an article that he wrote thirty
years ago about women in combat right
and if you went back 30 years ago I
think you looked at the Gallup poll
I'm almost guaranteeing you you would
have find that issue about 75 25 in the
country agreeing with him so he actually
lost his position Boeing lost an
executive his family now is out there
the safest place to be when there's a
mob is in the mob I think that this
letter is a welcome thing we should want
to play Red Rover Red Rover with them
like link arms okay let's do this my
last point is there was an author I
don't know if she signed this letter but
the woman who wrote American dirt it was
a I thought a fantastic novel that came
out in January and they cancelled her
book to her not because her book said
that illegal immigrants shouldn't come
to the country no her book was very
sympathetic and empathetic to the plight
of illegal immigrants and what they go
through the problem that the counselors
had with her was that she wasn't latina
enough doing part latina so they
cancelled her book tour they basically
tried to run her off the road
so I think if these people that are
authors and writers if they think wow
this has gone too far we should take
them up on it and all work together and
do what you've talked about before which
is share the risk together I agree with
myself as well Dana we should share the
risk